welcome to another backstage on making
apps beautiful so this is part two after
all five parts of the dev bite series
making apps beautiful have have been
released and i'm joined by yeah I'm yung
felix market I was here last time as
well I'm based here and sitting on the
end of a developer relations team and
I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm a software
engineer on the Android developer
relations team as well so we had some
good discussions last time but we've had
quite a lot of questions since so let's
talk about the elephant in the room to
begin with which is our source code so
in making apps beautiful we showed
different stages of the apps the app
that we were building and people are
asking if we were going to release the
source code and the answer is yes we're
going to do that we're going to do that
very shortly i'm just cleaning it up and
preparing it so that you can have a look
yeah that's fantastic i think people are
really excited about this really want to
dig through it again yeah and also had
to follow up questions from this yeah
yeah so we hadn't had a very popular
question on the cards layer but a lot of
people seem really excited about and
those are follow-up question from the
tiny met who was asking a bit more about
the specifics of implementing a a cart
lay out there to be dynamic so you can
have different different sized cards
together and I thought about this a bit
more and I think that it's lots of
different ways you can do this so one
way we've done it is that we have
actually used our own view group so if
you want to have something to with my
app's rating in s and you can just add
John Connor to it and I think that's a
bit more work involved you would
actually have to look at like it to look
at all running with your group and doing
your own measurements and layouts and
all that kind of stuff but if it's just
something as simple as you know
displaying different sized content and
you know just a list basically just say
you know the resizable layout might just
do the Majesty the trick into nine patch
in the background so there might be a
bit more work involved but simply using
a nine patch and different sized
containers might might work for you yeah
and just to follow up as well the person
was asking about a 48 deeper rid of
rhythm now for only talking
it's something that's similar to the
cards layout you know 48 dips just have
a look at it it might not be quite right
because typically a lot of these cards
you tend to have some rich content you
have some buttons that you can press as
well and if you try to squash all of
that information into a 48 dip layout
you might find that you don't have
enough space so you know I wouldn't say
that you need to follow the 48 dip
rhythm for cards layout to the letter
see what works well and provide the
better user experience and if you think
about how these carts layouts have been
used in the past for example the Play
Store there's obviously a big touch talk
in this case it's generally the
application icon or the movies icon or
something but something bit you can hit
so it's something to keep in mind when
you desire use interface yeah okay so uh
yeah thanks a follow-up questions good
yeah the tiny map ok so we had some some
questions around the the layout XML
files that we had four in the tablet
episode yeah the questions were actually
around using references rather than just
putting in you know your SW 600 DP
resource folders so do we want to sort
of yeah so one one big reason for this
is that you don't want to duplicate your
layouts right so if you want to reuse
your layouts it's as much easier to just
have references use reference references
rather than copy and pasting the files
multiple times in the APK you know
blowed up the APK as well but that's
another reason as well i mean before
android api level 13 its android a 3-2
honeycomb you only had these buckets
that allows you to look at the screen
size the actual screen size of the
device so like small normal large and
extra large screens so a tablet would be
an extra large screen bucket for example
and the problem is this this really
didn't give you fine grained control
because sometimes some device we get
classified as extra large but actually a
phone for example right but it's really
tricky to take this apart and and
actually provide a tablet on your layout
and the phone on the layout so above API
level 13 sorry api level 30 and above
and we actually introduced some resource
modifiers that you can use to look at
the available screen size you can look
at the smaller
that's available on the device and it
doesn't change for rotation so in this
case then you've been me when you want
to define a layout for the 4 Nexus 7 for
example like an axiom a 7-inch tablet
you would look at 600 EP or 10 inch
tablet would be a 720 DP so that's
that's really useful as well so and this
is where these references come in really
handy but you can just reuse your
layouts in different ways yeah just to
add to that as well with the the
qualifiers that we added you'll notice
that there now numerical so you're
talking about measurements it will make
physical sizes of devices where as
before when you had these arbitrary
buckets it was getting hard to classify
a device in large or extra-large because
the you know one of the strengths of the
Android ecosystem is the variety of
screen sizes so you can get small
tablets and large phones that that could
be large extra-large it could be medium
whereas when you talk about these
qualifies when you say 600 DP you're now
is putting a physical measurement around
the the dimensions of that device so
that's why it works a lot better yeah
yeah exactly and it's also poured note
that this is the available size so is
this the size that's actually available
to your application we're not just
talking about the physical the actual
screen size anymore we're talking about
what's actually available for your
application great so do we need
resources for every combination and not
necessarily good question ok so the the
android framework actually takes care of
this for you so and it tries to take a
good guess at what what are the best
resources for you to use if you don't
specify the various single combination
so for example if you if you specify a
phone layout and you specify a 7 inch
length using the 600 DP resource
qualifier and you'll certify a 10 inch
layer you know a bigger tablet layout it
would automatically pick the one that's
that goes for the 670 p for the 7 inch
tablet run so it's time to make a good
guess at what what's what's useful for
you and you can use it to your advantage
right so and I think it's a good good
idea to look at how what what's specific
to some of your layouts on how you can
how you can trim down on the layouts and
resources and images that you use yeah I
mean typically we can use the 10-inch
qualifier which is 720 DP the 67 inch
qualifier which is 600 DP
and then just not putting a qualify
which is your fallback so you've got
phone 7-inch tablets 10-inch tablets as
well so they tend to cater for really
the bulk of the devices unless you're
going for something very specialized
which generally we don't recommend
because you know maintainability becomes
a more difficult but yes three buckets
will get you very far that's right
that's right all right so uh so we
talked to tiny bit about designing for
petrol independence in our series and
i'll be happy we had the nexus s we had
me we had a tablet layout we had a phone
layout them so so let's talk about bit
about this a bit more and so you have
any good tips so when you want to design
a layout you want design an app for
pleasure independence what are the key
things you should pay attention to or
that you should do in your code yeah so
I so just to clarify by platform what we
actually meant is device device
independence so we're not we're not
linked to a particular device size but
look when you're specifying a layout the
the obvious thing is used oops use
density-independent pixels their their
physical measurements we have some great
documentation about this so please check
it out a DJ droid calm if you're not
sure but we also have a special
qualifier called or unit of measurement
called SP SP is actually what you should
be using for things like text views
because they're telling you that the
text that you have in these has things
like text views you're going to scale
that up based on the user preferences so
for example if the user has got their
accessibility settings set so that the
smallest font size is the minimum of 14
rather than 12 then SP will honor that
whereas dips won't so for text use ESPYs
for everything else use dips yeah and
what about pixels pixels never use
pixels never hard code pixel values in
your layout now obviously your assets
will tend to have pixels you know your
images will be will be using a pixel
coordinate system there's a very simple
mapping to dips but we already talked in
our in making apps beautiful those
divides about how you can use as you
use well so that they kind of stretch
nicely they make crop so we use Center
crop in all the examples that were used
yeah so uh yeah definitely yeah and you
should always so to go with pixels make
sure you don't use absolute layouts
absolutely outs were in a very early
version of the platform and we're
deprecated a long time ago our compiler
will warn you about it so please heed
those warnings and the other thing is
make sure you you provide a sort of
images or assets for the different
densities so that you're at runtime the
device isn't having to scale up a
low-resolution image on an xhdpi device
yeah exactly so that's actually what's
happening when you put in an image SS
and you provide it in a hex xhdpi or
mdpi a resource folder but you're not
specifying anything for ldpi or any
other any other resources would actually
get scaled up or scale down these extra
work for the for the device itself so
maybe not such a good idea so it's
always a good idea to to put these in
and you know processing before hand and
taking that one step further quite a lot
of apps will dynamically download images
right from the web so try and provide
those assets on your server or whatever
content you're getting so it's that it
comes down in the right resolution or
when you fetch it make sure you do the
conversion Senate you're not having to
do it at runtime but just a one download
cost at the time you download it for the
for the relevant resolution all right so
we had some some more questions as well
actually and before we go on let's see
if there's anyone in the on the Hangout
do you have any questions feel free to
join our hangouts on air there's a link
post on our Plus page so if you have any
questions feel free to just being a
positive chat and we'll put you up on
the screen if you want to be live on air
yeah so you can still ask questions and
not come on the screen if you like no
pressure yeah there's no pressure people
feel shy while we wait for people to ask
us questions we do have others that
people submitted Antonio said I'd like
to know what do you think about using
different fonts basically he was he was
saying what if I don't want to use
Roboto and I want to use the custom font
and so to be honest the answer is you
can use whatever font you like but at
the end of the day make sure you've
considered
the different aspects of the type of
font use so does it look great on a on a
3-inch phone screen but does it blow up
well onto a 10 inch tablet does it
support different languages accented
characters and so on so by all means we
do encourage you to to use your own
fonts and ship them with your app if
you'd like don't make assumptions about
which fonts are going to be available to
other than robota and droid sense don't
make assumptions about what users are
going to have but you know Antonia said
that he was from Spain so perhaps
there's a particular font that that
works well for for the accented
characters that you get in Spanish yeah
make sure that's actually an important
point as well it's when you're adding
custom phone if to be left to make sure
it supports other international
characters as well especially if you
have translated to a poor you want to
reach you know users in other countries
in other languages so when you make any
edit custom phone make sure it works for
all your languages that you have is
irrelevant yeah okay we had a li n de
Burgh also asking a question saying for
tablet optimizations Nick butcher he
said Nick but I'm talking pretty sure
it's Nick butcher has some interesting
tips for his design bites he had a
gridview in tablet and a listview on
phones how would I implement this is it
always a gridview just with different
layouts or would I switch between the
two actually the options yours you could
just go with a single grid view that's
one column on funds and multi columns on
a tablet or you could switch them around
and basically what you would do is using
those same resource qualifiers you could
have a value that indicated whether
you're in the grid view mode or the list
view mode and conditionally in your code
when you do a find nearby ID you would
cast them to the right type so actually
there is no right way to do it there's
multiple ways to do it which is always a
good thing so yeah you could I mean it
makes sense to use grid news on tablets
because and you can have especially if
you're doing like a tiled you I you want
to be able to use that extra space that
you get on tablets okay so we had some
episodes on performance tuning and you
know we we talked to in our episode a
little bit about
LRU cache the least recently used cash
it's great and I hope more and more
people are using it because as you saw
in our in our episode it makes a massive
difference to the performance of your
app and the experience as well and it
tries to do the right thing by holding
onto your images as long as possible so
the hard works done for you it's just a
matter of utilizing it yeah but there is
a there is some other libraries that you
can use to fetch yeah so so they didn't
talk in our series but they obviously
lots of other libraries you can use to
like fetch images through some
processing of the earth and all that
kind of stuff so you don't have to go
all of the work yourself every single
time you want to do something so one
really good library that we've been
using is called wally and there was a
talk at Google i/o this year that would
highly recommend for you guys to check
out that's library that lets open source
and as part of them is part of the
android framework as well yeah so we use
it extensively it's actually written by
a google of focus yeah and yeah it's
great I mean it a synchronizes your your
web requests yeah and so you can
basically have a very you spawn civ user
interface that brings images in the
background for you yeah and so it
actually it's very easy to use actually
you basically say here's an image here's
the URL here's the view i want to put it
and it goes off does it automatically
and update anyone the right threatens
all of this kind of stuff for it which
is really handy and but you can also use
for other things not just images so if
for example built-in i think is support
for Jason aslam so if there's some Jason
you want to fetch from a server you can
use the volume library for Dennis font
and it gives it back to JSON object in
JSON array and its really really handy
and you know they're all sorts of other
really cool features in there for
example casing for you has really good
cancellation policies you want to move
want to stop request you can group them
together all the kind of stuff but how
do you recommend checking that out
having said that a lot of other
libraries out there as well that said
that people are using these days as well
and one of the ones for stick acid at
somebody mentioned on the youtube
comment so have a look at you sir have a
look at your app and see what which
library does exactly what you need to do
yep so that's Picasso not picasa like
the
II the photo app and website all right
and I guess the good news that since
since we recorded the episode is that
actionbarcompat is finally out so when
we recorded it we were like coming soon
but it's great it's released and it's
part of the support library so please
grab it use it let us know what you
think about it yeah we also have a deaf
bite on using actionbarcompat so it's a
good way to get you started it's a good
primer so you know now we've had some
questions around a while should i use
actionbarcompat ladies actionbarsherlock
actionbarsherlock widely popular we
talked about it in our in our dev bite
as well so if you're comfortable with
actionbarsherlock go ahead keep using it
we you know both are great library so
use what works for you what we're going
to be doing is as we update the action
bar in the android framework let's say
we do it in a future version of the the
android framework we're going to make
sure that actionbarcompat is also kept
up to date so that's one of the things
that you'll get straight away from
actionbarcompat but you know use what
works well for you that's right that's
right mmm yeah so am the navigation
drawers always an interesting topic and
we kind of shut it off a bit i think in
one of the last episodes that we did and
that's that's part of the support
library as well isn't it it is you can
grab the classes you can just drop it in
and start using it the nice thing is we
talked about all of the subtleties that
come with the the standardized android
action bar and you get those you don't
need to sit down implementing the nice
beautiful fade in fade out or the bezel
swipe since it's all taken care of for
you so using standard components is
always a good thing you don't have to
write it and paste the code yourself
that's right hmm okay the last thing I
think we should talk about we didn't
really talk about it is notifications
yeah so that's in the sucess a
notification compact in support drive as
well so in android for dot one jellybean
we introduced new types of notifications
you can have explained notifications so
you can display a different type of
notification
painting on with it expanded not
expanded its really useful for email
messages for example so you can see all
of you all of your emails in unification
list so you can minimize them only see
that you have you know some unread
messages and this this is something that
we have added to the notification compat
in the support library as well but the
problem here is that an expanded
notifications are not backwards
compatible so if you if you use the
notification compat builder that's in
the support library you can add all of
these things to notification but it
doesn't get displayed on lower versions
of Android unfortunately and but the
good thing you for use its transparency
you have to worry about version check
some of the kind of stuff is simply
isn't displayed and one really big hint
I I have though is that if you make use
of these experimental vacations or
notification actions you know you can
have buttons at the bottom of
notification so you can apply sort of a
your course on my back straightaway make
sure you always supply a content intent
and the cotton intent is the one that's
files when you going to use at absolute
vacation and this is basically what's
get fired on lower version of android so
gingerbread for example we don't have
support for these extra identification
actions right so it's always really
really important to specify the uniform
the content intent that gets fired off
in somebody taps your notification
awesome well it doesn't look like we
have anyone asking any questions on the
Hangout I think we've covered the the
sort of questions that we had leading up
to this so on that note I guess we'll
say goodbye thank you for joining us
yeah thank you and we'll see you next
time yeah see you next time thanks